My husband and I met when we were working the same job.
I was walking a fashion show that he was attending and watching.
And I love how now, five years later,
we still get to model together and work together.
And this was our first family shoot with all of our kids,
which felt so, so special.
Shot this a few months back when whimsy was only six weeks old.
And it's crazy to think about that
she's been on almost 10 shoots ever since she was born
three months ago.
A lot of people don't realize that both lucky and I are models.
And we've been working ever since we've been really young.
I got scouted when I was fourteen.
He started at a young age as well.
So this is something that we've been doing for a while.
Shot this GQ hype cover on a little ranch in Texas.
We got to hang out with a bunch of different animals.
The kids absolutely loved it.
We also shot a GQ couples quiz,
which was nerve wracking, but it turned out really nice.
Shot a handful of Lux and it was so hot in Texas.
It was over 100 degrees, so we were sweating all day long,
especially carrying animals around.
But it was all worth it. Last shot of the day was the hype cover.
We shot this right when the sun was setting,
which made it so magical. And as soon as we wrapped,
I couldn't Wait to get home and have some ice cream on the couch.